hello everybody uh I'm sitting down
today to play some Lego bricktales which
I'm already feeling is a very good vibe
based on this like Star menu music it's
kind of beautiful we're obviously live
on Twitch which is why you see in twitch
chat hi twitch chat say nice things to
YouTube
um this is a new game from Thunderball
and clockstone very big thank you to
Thunderball for sponsoring stream slash
for sponsoring this video they asked me
to play it basically is what that means
uh and yeah the game is out now PC it's
on Steam epic game store Gog PS5 Xbox
series X and S Nintendo switch PS4 and
Xbox One
um and if you don't know anything about
this game
[Music]
I mean I guess I guess I'll show you but
I was into it based on what I've seen
because it's like got a bunch of like
Lego diorama kind of biomes that they've
built that look absolutely beautiful
there's a story mode that takes you
through them and there's a lot of like
Puzzles and building this Brick by Brick
building mechanic that just looks really
cool so I was like I I'm down to try it
and uh that's what we're gonna do also
thank you zero two byz
the two ones up all right let's give it
a shot let's hit play
it just looks like a really chill
experience which I I'm always in need of
a treasure
my grandchild I hope this letter finds
you well sorry
my grandchild I hope this letter finds
you well
I have made a groundbreaking discovery
but I'd like to show you that's how all
people sound that's I only have one old
person voice and that's it
also a helping hand or two can't hurt
the potential of this is incredible
when you arrive at the theme park take
the elevator down to my laboratory I
will wait for you there all right all
right old man let's go
let's do it
okay I am playing now some keyboard for
reference everybody and I am playing on
PC
um and yeah this is my first time
booting up the game uh
I love that so I guess I haven't shared
it um that much publicly but I've
currently been working through the
entire
Lego Botanical collection
um I've built three of them so far and I
love these
these leaves they use on a ton of them
one of my favorites is the Bonsai and
when you do the cherry blossom Bonsai
Lego Botanical collection set they use
the little pink frogs it's really cool
I'm a big fan of the botanical
collection it's beautiful
it's kind of one explore I shoot the
Laboratories that place in the middle
but yeah
stuff out just take a little look around
yeah what's happened here
a little bloody shirt my guy
I've built many things with these in my
day also
cool
what could go wrong
I didn't even verify that that was from
my Grandad to be honest
who knows
technically your grandchild but yeah
oh no
that's very cute in the middle of wiring
up my invention and what you just
witnessed is what we in the business
call a rapid unplanned disassembly
in layman's terms too much power make
big boom very good very good very good
so not only am I now trapped here but it
took the whole power grid down with it
we'll need to restart the main generator
eventually but first could you start the
emergency generator okay old man tell me
what to do
all right
I'm coming
look at the way they walk up and down
stairs oh my God
I love it okay
I strongly agree Cockney Chava the the
Lego games have always had a really good
sense of humor and I actually reviewed a
lot of the Lego games for IGN I feel
like I've always just found them to be
like
comfort food like they're a really nice
thing to play if you're stressed out or
whatever and
um I was on the board of an organization
that recently shut down because we got
too busy the owner got too busy that
focused on the relationships between
mental health and video games and I
pretty strongly feel like uh Lego game
is a good example of of positive mental
health experience with playing video
games that very Zen music's really nice
often calming cutesy funny
um usually very polished
um so you're not going to get any like
frustrating game breaking bugs or
anything like that and the stuff that's
familiar to your childhood so they're
just they're just nice and comfy to play
should have replaced this old thing
years ago those wires are always coming
unplugged go on throw the lever
[Music]
seems fine
all my washing machines do that
oh is that uh the name of one of Elon
musk's kids
that's crazy
I'm not a genie and you don't get three
wishes that's not what I said I asked if
you were one of Elon musk's kids
your grandfather made me years and years
ago he always called me Rusty cute but
while I was out there in space I made
new friends and with these alien Nick's
name
elonx crime Scout you lack the required
frequency
synthesization modules to properly
pronounce it the closest approximation
would be
plural flip that
the blue r d confused my accent because
we'd say blood or flea blood blue I
don't know how to say that in Australian
accent but thank you for letting me know
how to pronounce that child's name
but you can call me Rusty cute
I thought I lost you somewhere years ago
oh yes I did get lost for a bit after
you shot me into space remember but I
saw some wonderful things and now I'm
back
I'm curious
excellent walk my child the lights are
back on based on your problem-solving
skills we could be related haha
not playing around old man all right I
came here
to do bricktails not to be sassed by the
elderly
grandpar is trapped Let's help him let's
go okay
but uh what else do I need to do my guy
I'm not actually sure
okay
let's hover up well I can't hop out no
this is the perfect chance to show you
what I can do let me teach you the power
of building Okay cool so this is like
the main mechanic of the game from my
understanding
construct things
learn how to manipulate bricks
let's learn how to build
okay
that's pretty simple
let's pair the stairs
all right let's do it
I guess 2.21 gigawatts was one too many
looks like the generator believe some
fuses replace that because some of our
replacement pieces at least say please
old man I'll come over there
um oh I'll slap the pants off of you
I'm going to rotate brick so like the
brick
click click oh click it got it got it
got it got it got it okay
shift
cool
okay
pretty simple
assembling a missing fuse
um okay that would be a click
no click the two ball click
thank you
I'm gonna do that wrong I did I didn't
put the blue one on that's my bad but
everything's facing the right direction
now
beautiful
how to control the camera I think we're
already doing that okay
yep makes sense
okay yeah it's pretty standard find the
other brick you say
it's probably this way which is shift
that was like way hotter than it should
have been
and I wonder how like intricate this is
gonna get basically you do Lego in the
game which is cool
learn how to use the brick palette you
telling me
okay
let's remove bricks
okay that's easy
when we have many bricks we place them
in a palette with everything nice and
tidy we can concentrate on building okay
try building a little Tower
you know what I would love to build a
little towel build a little Tower
happy just happy little towel I have the
little towel horse very nice very nice
foreign
fuses okay by leaving USA I sure am the
I mean the
um just for reference everybody on
YouTube uh I titled the stream before I
disappear
um which just means I'm gonna be away
for a couple of weeks it's nothing that
drastic
I promise
um
uh yeah I also like though you know play
watch listen and probably no episode of
good news gaming next week there will be
one
tonight but probably not next week
great now a pair of the pipes to get the
Hydraulics going again
didn't do these yet though oh this is
gonna be a bridge
learn about brick validity and
simulation okay when building more
complex things there's some rules to
follow brick setup pre-place can't be
modified like these two by four plates
that serve as anchors cool
what I think of My Chemical Romance
thank you for asking it was incredible
they're very good that said um turns out
I don't know a lot of their songs I
would have thought that I did but I know
like every album Sorry every song on
Sweet Revenge but I don't know every
song on black parade and I was like I
don't know some of these that's a shame
rule number one bricks have to be
connected to an anchor otherwise they
are not valid okay so see the two by two
and two of four bricks they are not
connected to the plates on the bottom
hence they are invalid
you hate to see it
what does simulate to nothing okay
gotcha bricks have to be placed within
the dash line see that two by two brick
over there it's peeking out of the
allowed area
yeah
now here's the next cool thing
okay
look back
right okay but there was three options
what if I wanted to do all of them
bricks can't float in the air they'll be
invalid and vanish
if I want to solve it that fast though
oh I had to do all three at once it
makes sense that checks out
build a walkway across the Gap I would
love to
[Music]
oh this could actually get like very
puzzly
I mean if this is just stop like part
one right this this could get
didn't get spicy out here
do I think would prevent breakages
that's all right no
um
I'm probably overthinking it I'm like
but do I need to think about physics
like should I reinforce
the edges
let's do it you know let's just do it
let's just have fun with it let's get
crazy with it
[Music]
and then two more over here
um bridge the gap in the middle we're
gonna just like layer them on
you know what I'm saying
oh am I out of brick Sam okay
surely this isn't going to work
he's not as heavy as I expected
thank you ultimate Greg
I wonder how this will feel with the
controller naturally Mouse feels like
best method yeah it is on Console but um
again based on what I had seen of the
game to me it seemed like a good fit for
mouse and keyboard because of the
building stuff soon
that's what I felt like doing
learn how to move bricks vertically I
think we've already kind of got that
down
brick
that's the up button
on the screen or e oh that does make it
a lot easier
shift e
whoa cool
to lock its vertical position
cool okay
reconnect the pipes I would love to
use up down to place the pipe pieces
Shadows help to sorry I am covering part
of the UI here
how does help with placement you say
oh okay that's actually super easy
um and then it's going to be e
and shift
uh cute
uh
cute
nope nope
what about this is that oh that is a
pipe okay
thank you
you're still stuck though
now turn the Hydraulics machine back on
all right I would love to
nothing would bring me greater pleasure
than than doing that
over here I think
no maybe from up here
oh here
build a bridge here
yeah
okay
that's cute
no no e
did you want it to step down maybe
[Music]
that's just gonna fall oh yeah
oh no
uh there and then this one
this is a mess what am I doing
maybe I need to extend those a bit
further that's probably what I need to
do right what did it say
shift
you can duplicate any brick you already
placed by holding shift before selecting
and moving it
now that didn't duplicate it
uh by holding shift before selecting and
moving it shift
instruction trunk
four
hold shift select and move
maybe it doesn't refer to the little
pieces
uh I am currently just building a bridge
nothing may break
I should actually want to see what it
does
that move up or down
okay
[Music]
that that's probably correct we just
make it a little ladder type thing right
that one can go there and then
one more on the top that seems good that
seems good that seems good to me
hmm
of course
move everything back one
cool
those are good Wheels you've got on you
my guy
okay and then I just have to go back
over there
beautiful we've done it I'm a genius I
fully was reading the the cylinder ones
as though they'd like have some sort of
hydraulic system which is on me
hello grandpa I've made it
definitely yes in favor of this being a
good educational tool not in schools
though for kids
I've told this uh Story Probably a
million times before but the way that I
actually got into video games
was I mean my neighbor had games but my
mom got my sister and I into educational
games on PC
so
um even though she wasn't a gamer she
found about found out about educational
games so my sister and I started playing
them on PC and then it just expanded
from that
and then we got demo discs and cereal
boxes and I was playing the same two
levels of Age of Empires because we
couldn't afford to actually buy the game
good stuff
I met some really friendly aliens who
repaired me and let me travel with the
Multiverse with them helping people they
swapped out the multi-functional arms
you gave me for zero point gravity
particle generator of course
of course
exactly how Laura it was catalogs yeah
yeah I played a lot of Age of Empires on
that demo disc
um again we didn't have a lot of money
when I was a kid and so I appreciated
what I could get I also played most
Nintendo 64 games as a kid rented so I
only played them for a week because we
couldn't really afford to buy them so I
always had other people save files and
rarely was able to finish things until I
got a little bit older
they swapped out the multifunctional
um so you gave me for a zero point
gravity particle generator
ah of course that old three-point guard
practical generator simple technology
for an inventor such as myself
anyway it's great to have the two of you
here now Cub let me show you my
invention I would love to see it let's
do it
[Music]
what's up what's happening
I was experimenting and made the
groundbreaking discovery of how to
create portals
it's taken me years but I think we got
it to run now isn't it incredible yeah I
think I may have also reviewed
let me check if I did Lego dimensions
wondering if I did that for IGN
I did not
but I did play a bunch of Lego
Dimensions
um
forgetting which ones I did review for
IGN I definitely did some of them
but not that one I'm just gonna be nice
to my webcam a little bit smaller
what the park oh yes I am it might be in
a state of mild discombobulation oh no
oh no
the Maya she's been telling me for ages
if I don't get the pot cleaned up she'll
close down this eyesore of her place and
have the land seized
I got so distracted by the portal I
totally forgot there's no way I can
clean all this in time
the extent of disrepair is truly
pervasive have you considered splicing
local space-time with a spatio-temporal
alternate reality Drive
that's genius
it's simple when Quantum strings vibrate
in face with disturbances in the
microwave background radiation
well slow down I don't uh my grandchild
here this is really cute
I'm going to Melbourne from San
Francisco on the 23rd any tips for that
flight I'm scared uh why are you scared
you'll be fine it's a long flight the
longest flight I've ever done was 17
hours that was Texas to Sydney
that was long but there's nothing you
can really do just make sure you move
your feet deep vein thrombosis ain't
playing around
I'm so sorry my apologies let me start
over it fixes things that are broken
perfect that's exactly what we need I'd
like to buy three do you accept credit
cards it's very cute that won't be
necessary I possess the knowledge and
Equipment required to assemble it for
free from pots I have seen lying around
your property
definitely take a switch
yeah I try to I always like take videos
to edit on planes
um so I do editing or just drink a lot
of water
don't eat all the food they give you way
more food than you need for the lack of
movement try to move your feet just kick
your legs whatever you can
take books
excellent now we only need sufficient
energy to operate the machine like
electricity
yes but something more powerful better
than electricity oh happiness crystals
of course
they're the greatest source of energy
I've ever encountered on my travels
these crystals generate in local
space-time Wells when the mean comic
positive Delta exceeds the O value of
Stephen Rusty we've been over this I
don't know these words oh I mean my
grandchild can't understand a thing that
you're saying
I will simplify
we help people to make them happy
happiness crystals appear okay yeah
let's uh
get get some some Capital uh capitalism
in your happiness there for you
fix the theme park everybody is happy to
go for ice cream great I vote we take
the Mayo down from the inside out
the portal
nice
nice this is really cute
all right well hack into your portal and
set everything up okay
let's go
[Music]
appears to be some kind of jungle so
you'll go collect some happiness
crystals and we can clean up this mess
recycling well then off you go
let's do it
see your grandpa
you can always travel back to Grandpa's
amusement park using the return to
Grandpa option
every good game has a return to Grandpa
option
the lady beetles
all right
well now big it's gonna be
small plane crash landed somewhere in
the mountains right before us I could
see parachutes opening I hope everyone's
okay we have to go help those people
right away all right nud
um but what can we build it
okay
a set of stairs
bloody oath
the maximum step height you can climb is
three plates or one brick okay
the minimum width path is two Norms that
makes sense
interesting I see a conundrum I'm just
gonna have to double some of them right
so I can travel three
oh the jungle music is popping off
[Music]
that should work oh is that not
connected at the top
we just do that right
the top bit oh no of course it's not
connected okay
we do have to
properly connect that that's too high
now
but it's gonna have to be that way so
like that
um I need to change the height of the
bottom one because yeah I don't think I
can I can go that high right that's
wrong
yeah okay
all right
yeah you're gonna go higher
you just throw some of this out just get
out of here get out of here
uh it's off anyway and yeah this is
gonna be too long again so let's
put this one under here
here
no I should just change the angle
e
and I can pull that forward
I don't know if I need to
we're just doing the same thing I did
last time I might be I am very tired
that
is four
how many the maximum step out you can
climb is three plates of one brick the
minimum width the path is two knobs so
that they don't have to be that that far
apart is the difference
so you can make it shorter
and I don't think I have limited
that should work
and then you move over here you go up
here
with who
trip
there e
no
also no
get out of here there and then there
that should work
I keep getting worried that it's gonna
Buckle at the end he's a lightweight
robot
can you grab multiple bricks at the same
time
um I don't think so
oh I kind of want to explore down there
though
I also would love to build my way up
here let's well you know what let's
explore before we get further just
because I want to
I can't get past the trees anyway okay
never mind disregard disregard
and what's up with this some kind of a
crowbar
Bridge time
ooh okay
there's one to focus on the power hmm I
don't know is that a railing
I've not seen some of these pieces
before so I don't know what that
function would be which is kind of fun
ah
what are you what is for what
for what purpose do you serve my friend
maybe it's aesthetic I don't know if it
has a function
you know what I mean
also did that I know
but we can't uh
nope okay I'm not sure
and then what are these here for to
support the middle
oh there are 13 of those oh
okay
[Music]
I see hang on maybe that goes like that
[Music]
and then we put that on top of it no
that doesn't work I was like is that a
support
I suppose not uh
that might work
um
if I add a little step
not sure
and then another one
right is that hitting it
yeah that seems correct then
we just do a couple of those I think
that should work
all right I still don't know what these
are for
has anyone seen those in a Lego set
before what are they
do you know what those are
chat
if it's a railing
I mean the robot's not gonna just fall
off if it's is it just to look cute you
reckon
because I like it up here
even if it's not necessary
I wonder if I need it
we could put it on there to make it look
nice no it won't go on this the fridge
oops on the bridge pot I'm making though
might not be necessary I don't know
let's let's build it and then simulate
it and find out
leave that one in
just a bit there
little guys over here again
little guy little guy little guy big guy
hmm
it got real thin all right let's just
see what happens oh are they floating
I think they might be floating oh well I
don't care if I fail
they want even there okay oh the whole
thing is red
which means that height is off can we do
it the other way around
make them lower
hmm
and then they aren't connected okay okay
okay okay okay
go undergo key
and then you go over here now that's not
connected okay
okay that under there
some real engineering I'm definitely not
like doing the right thing
but I'm having a good time
uh that's only wrong because of those
all apart we could just maybe just add
this in here hang on hang on come on up
up my guy
okay
see what happens
with those not connected maybe they want
they want okay hang on hang on maybe you
can't just build whatever you want right
in theory it'll work
the weight's wrong the weight's wrong so
my abomination
does not work
abomination
was just an abomination
what if I reinforce it from the bottom
uh hang on
there
hmm
so no matter what this thing is well I I
keep treating it as though those are
supporting it on the ground but they
aren't really
so what is
foreign
[Music]
if the railings are required
to keep
things together so let's go back to the
original layout
[Music]
maybe the white rods are supports for a
rope Bridge a rope Bridge
I am definitely thinking that supports
at this point yes
that they'll just like keep multiple
pieces sort of
together
um
so again am I right I'm thinking that
these weren't even really connected to
the ground because it overhangs like
what I'm actually building in the
in the forest is like pretty high up so
I'm thinking these aren't actually
support beams
right
I wonder if I could have just put these
over the top and they would have
supported it from the top end
let's try it
let's give it a try
that's too low though
I'm gonna okay okay
ideas are happening
oh no I wanted to move the whole thing
back there
go like that you just connect the two
if you know what I mean
why is that wrong because you're not
connected to anything else
or is it not connected under there it's
not connected a little bit okay
oops perspective is way off
uh and uh key
and then now well these can't go in
angles
so my plans that oh what is this
oh there are even more pieces than I
gave it credit for
okay
I'm thinking
that this would be easier if I had a
reference of what it looked like right
um but that maybe the whole thing needs
to be flat and these are like those like
kind of decorative pieces that hold
everything together like a glue on the
top
and then we have
ropes
you understand what I'm saying you
understand
pick me up
thank you squeals
um so we're gonna add a bunch of these
as supports again even though I'm not
positive that's what they do
we're gonna add them anyway
gotta step up that's fine
nope
damn it
the size is just not quite right
um
it it
looks good
oh sorry I'm sure this video will be
very painful to watch for anybody who's
um
more informed in like Lego sets right I
love those
Botanical sets but I've never built a
bridge before
also
I've never been very shape smart
definitely not a strong suit
keep thinking that these should make it
smooth oh these as well
there are so many things
I'm scared of the amount of things
should I be utilizing all of these does
this go on that
it does they do fit on top of each other
oh there's so many things
I'm so overwhelmed
if you're screaming give me tips then
Strider
you good to help me out
hmm
focus on the palette there's so much
stuff in the palette
[Music]
I'll leave it all back over a little
this has got to make these flat that's
surely that's
and then this is gonna go on top of that
[Music]
but then how is it not gonna fall what
are you here for hahaha
small cylinders are for top side right
are they
pretty sure it's a rope Bridge Okay so
so then I probably need to connect
if we're giving a rope Bridge an attempt
right
then the cylinders do go up here
which is fair
and is it that I can make some kind of
like a hanging like suspension system
from the top
is that a possibility
foreign
I'm sure this is wrong
there's no way there's just no way
that's the right thing to do here
no way using the white pole with the
vertical cylinder to hang the bricks
the white pole
this with the oh
it didn't occur to me that that would
functionally work okay
so then that would go on here
and then this would go
um under here
that does work that way
okay maybe we can connect the whole top
side of the bridge that way to start
with
see if it works
I don't know
phew I have to do that first then Q
then that goes there
uh that's e
I think
I could buy that and then maybe these
bits
probably not
probably not no I'm probably not that
okay
um another one of these
and I keep wondering if the amount of
them that I have is relevant probably
not either
okay
but but now what's
that you told me to hang the cylinders
from the Rope bits
use the 1x6 under each of your posts to
lay the bridge you think
uh if you've gotten how to move
independently okay
one by six
goes like that
there
back
it does feel bridgy
which is definitely in a way I didn't
expect
over here
this one here
I have it done right outside that
shouldn't be that way right no that is
right okay
uh e
again she do be looking sort of bridgy
but I can't connect these to each other
I mean that's going to support the
weight of
some of it
I can't lift it okay
do you know maybe
hey I can always try it and see if it
works
um but obviously we need to
those can't go far enough for that
either
it's not connected back one
is that connected
no that is hovering
okay
little oh
you're accidentally moving stuff I've
really made a mess of this whole
workspace
[Music]
yeah and then along
e
yeah
I have a cute cute cute oh gosh
I need to move stuff back into order
it's too messy
I apologize I've messed it all up it's
it's awful it's hideous I've made a
disaster of this place
I'm ashamed of me this is actually like
you're gonna step on all of this
just so that it's a little easier to
look at
and not pick up the wrong block
nope you gotta go all the way up there
you go and then you go over here
okay
so then this goes Q
but these aren't actually connected
now they are
but it's weird I mean that could maybe
be where these go no that's strange no
that doesn't make any sense
um
we need to go first I'm pretty sure
get back over
okay
nope
there we go
there we go
all right
listen
do we maybe now get to use the more of
these supports
because he's gonna flip no matter what
right
because they still didn't work that way
why an odd number of rope
what do you mean
what do you mean
this is rope
um there's only an odd number of these
only five of these or no they're by five
not sure all right I'm gonna keep doing
what I think is the right thing to do
here
which is maybe this
I think this is Buckle in the middle
but let's give it a shot
oh I'm out of those again okay keep
forgetting that
uh
because there are a lot more small
pieces than big pieces
why did you give me nine of these guys
oh you can order return stuff oh I
didn't realize that it might have told
me that and I forgot that's very handy
okay
I keep feeling like that is good for
support but maybe I'm wrong
the auto return is very nice
maybe think of it as an Indiana
jones-like rope Bridge with gaps between
planks
I suppose that's possible okay yeah um
that would mean doing this right so if
we add more cylinders and then more rope
bridgey bits that
that will look cute
but how do I avoid it going lower it has
to
do
q e
it has to have a little step down
uh e
h
beep
right
and then we would put the next cylinder
on
but then it's not connecting to anything
no it doesn't make sense
because uh
what is holding this up really do you
know what I mean
all right let's just see what happens
okay just like I actually did stuff with
Lego as a kid
um maybe these go back on top
go high
he eat yeah
that's right I keep running out of these
pieces
and I keep forgetting that I'm running
out of these pieces so it's not that
if that just goes down for foundational
purposes
that piece is useless
it doesn't make sense
but you know what maybe there are more
than there's more than one right answer
okay and then I liked putting these
under here
seemed like a cool thing to do
cool guy move okay
and then the robot just jumps
and then in the middle the robot just
jumps that's what happens I don't make
the rules
but there's only okay no there's more
than one of those there
picking up what I'm putting down
I don't think the physics of this makes
sense though
I don't think it makes any sense
um but uh as all good Engineers say
build it first ask questions later baby
all right
yeah if you just fixed up my problems
please
could you just sort of
[Laughter]
hmm
I still don't know why there are only
three of them
hmm
okay okay you put two in the middle
am I out of the small pieces oh oh there
are just a lot of these
the only reason you'd give me an uneven
amount of the big pieces is if you want
me to rotate them right
if I'm just thinking about it all wrong
um so we're gonna do
okay
and then
these are gonna fall surely they're
gonna fall
there's no way but let's try it let's
try it let's give it a try let's see why
the robot dies
there's no way this works no Brown okay
yeah the middle is actually just not
supported by anything currently these
pieces are just like
they're only supported by that
so we need like under supports
which
is that gonna work the way I think it is
unsure
let's try it
where did I put that there Q
that's there's no way that's enough okay
and then you let's put right in the
middle
but underneath
and just hope for the best man
just sort of just sort of cover up all
our mistakes pretend they aren't there
whoever dies first is a dummy
not me
I'm an engineer
[Laughter]
yeah functional Bridge baby let's go
[Laughter]
all right
where
oh
same spot but not as fast I would like
to see it again
[Music]
okay
so this still doesn't have enough
support
we do still have two of these pieces so
let's add a little support under here
right
let's see what happens
again as all great Engineers say
left over
is there a way for me to connect these
pieces no I don't think there is
need more
pieces on the bottom
I mean that really isn't doing very much
at all
if I move the position does that help
I also like feel like it should be flat
rather than this weird step system I've
created
yeah that's where it's falling apart
okay
okay my guy I ain't got a lot left in me
because yeah that's a weird whatever I
did there
that of course that's not holding itself
together
from the top
we'll hold itself together from the top
there's a gap there but that seems less
likely to collapse in my humble opinion
and move this one up right
and just give that a try
you know
maybe maybe
oh hang on
let's get rid of these two
no
why are there so many of you oh okay
it was worse
it was worse
definitely worse
make a two layer connected floor bridge
I don't know what that means
mirrored the starting points but in the
middle
um
well
is the bridge connected in the middle at
all
no
that's not oh it is underneath but only
by the outsides
so
maybe all these support structures
actually go underneath and not on top
and then we just cover our shame
no that's definitely not right no this
no Bridge has ever looked like this
before this is a disaster
the worst Bridge ever known to man
absolutely there's no way there's just
no way
no Lego Bridge has ever been designed to
look this way and yet here I am I'm
still doing it
damn you all right I probably gotta go
up rather than down
it's just gonna go up
curse you Lego robot
um
oh I made it so intricately too
[Music]
no no this is gonna help I still feel
like these need to be supported on each
other and they're not
maybe the white pieces aren't supposed
to go on the outsides I've never built a
Lego Bridge before
the bridge was flat and it fell apart
straighter
the bridge was flat and it fell apart
[Music]
the ends of the bridge are unsupported
from underneath I'm in agreement
support them with help of the Rope sides
long pieces across the bridge Maybe
I don't know how to help them with
support of those sides
because even if I were to just flipped
them that way that wouldn't
actually give it more support
you know what I mean
hmm
do you need more support on the start of
the bridge
I think maybe the big pieces are bad but
can't be full of these that wouldn't
work either
these are definitely to go over the top
I really think that it being flat on the
top is actually correct to be honest
is that up
yeah
so actually these probably need to go
home too
and this probably does go
like that and like that just for
for design purposes realistically
that would be what they would do
you see what I'm saying
and then the whole underneath of my
bridge is where everything goes wrong
okay
that is what I think aesthetically
they would intend for the bridge to look
like
with the hallway
so then we just gotta come out here and
support it we gotta just support it we
gotta support the bridge the first well
my six don't really connect to the edge
right
um
I don't understand the question if I'm
being completely honest
unclear
I could use some social emotional
support yeah me too me too
me too
um okay let's
connect
these two
from underneath just to stop thank you
because that seems like a thing you
would want to do
which I don't think I did last time
is use
those under there
um
what about these starting bits because
that's good support when we have more
Bridge
hmm
the start is not supported though
this is way more challenging than I
expected again
there's this thing they say about
writers
um no one's a writer there are just
people who are bad at math
and I'm
shockingly bad at math
um
and anything to do with engineering
just terrible to be honest
I feel like it makes sense we gotta work
on these boys
this is definitely gonna end up being
much easier than we thought yes
I don't want it I don't want to look it
up again I do feel like you'd probably
be in for a easier time if you built a
Lego Bridge before but I this this one
outsmart me
why are there 14 of these
I the people want to know why are there
so many
[Music]
it's just it's just a lot of pieces
foreign
[Music]
that seems okay because these are all
too wide right
yeah
and then these are maybe just all
supports
where would we place the others
um
seems like weird overhang
this does look bridgy though
oh boy does it look bridgy
do you know what I mean
sure does look
like a bridge
the lack of symmetry um
very bad at that one more about and then
eat nope it's there and then he
the lack of symmetry is is
a cause for concern I'll be honest
so just shove you one more over
you know I've never seen much more
bridgy than that in my whole life and
then what if these are just sort of
nope
too many of them
it doesn't work
but like damn girl you you looking like
a bridge
actually more like a
like a train track
and that one's off
because they didn't move that forward no
why is that so far off oh because that
isn't even connected yeah that's a
problem okay that one has to go back
[Music]
oh well
um what have I done
how does it not look symmetrical at all
now
what did I do
I really thought I was making it
symmetrical and I'm not
this is um oh okay
this bridge will not best me
are there multiple ways to complete
challenges challenge is just one way I
actually don't know I don't know
no idea
uh probably
let's put all these back no
let's put you back up
right you belong
up my friend
I wonder if
would these people no no they wouldn't
no
I wonder if there's a way to use the
other four of these
that's yeah not even connected that has
to go back surely
you'd want the extra support oh there's
actually only extra support on that side
that's interesting
I'm making the same mess as last time
but um feeling more confident about it
so
not those dark connect
that's just a gap
foreign
[Music]
I don't think I need them for anything
still six more of these
[Music]
I'm gonna go for symmetry
Lego's always symmetrical
no it's wrong it's not right it's not
right
wouldn't the brown pieces be good for
the gaps I I think the brown pieces and
I'm only basing this on the things that
I have built
I mean we could see if this would work
but I think it's not it's just gonna
break
um the brown pieces are more like
decorative than structural
I don't think
I mean this is definitely gonna fall
because I haven't supported them
properly but
it didn't fall there
he took longer to fall
than normal okay
so that's actually pretty well supported
this is obviously not supported at all
there's like nothing
um
let's see if that makes a good photo
it did make him go further that is that
is structurally sound over there baby
we have a structurally sound region
over there
you will not best me robot
not on this
that they are my daughter's wedding
oh no that's supposed to be the whole
way over
did I get one on that side yeah
yes
and you see it again he falls here right
because that just wasn't connected to
anything at all hmm
curious
I'm not handling this very well here we
go there and then there
also not gonna work but you know
one step at a time baby
um
do I have symmetry I do have symmetry I
feel like these could help a bit more
there's no way it's gonna work it's not
in the middle there's there's nothing
supporting this whole midsection
hmm
I really appreciate the sport
okay
you ain't got no gaps now
but
um
should I be using everything
I'm stressing myself out dude
I wonder if there's something else I can
use these for
it does look like a bridge thank you
it does look like a bridge I've achieved
that it's bridgy as hell
honestly I didn't even do math in my
last two years of high school which is
why my report card's so good I just
dropped out of math
put 1x6 on the sides of the middle
underneath
sides of the middle underneath like even
with the railings what
what's the goal of the game oh so the
goal of the game itself is not just this
bridge puzzle but I'm very stuck on
um
the goal of the game is
uh effectively like there's a story
taking you through these different like
Lego biomes you explore stuff there's a
story you just have to build stuff to
get to the to the things
[Music]
have I done that before
I probably have
there's only one of them
no
no
makes sense to me
I'm gonna do it one more time to see why
he lost support
that was that didn't happen last time
that's just because of the round pieces
can still go up that high can't you no
so those give that support
and there was no uneven on Brown pieces
for some reason too
it was
like why are there 12 of those
for the sides
seems odd
I mean
that I mean no it's no no no no no no
no
yeah the middle piece is just like not
even connected to itself really
um hmm
I feel like removing this is helpful in
time being
uh I only have two of these
and if we just just connect them there
just add a little connecty bits
sort of here
then now they need to be there
then something
okay well that's now good
does the brown help now
all across slabs that don't have the
Rope won't hold
um
with the two 1x6 is supported from
underneath well
yeah but I don't think they have any
they can't support its own weight from
underneath you know
there's no way that's right either
you look like garbage darling
who's that
yeah now that's not connected to
anything so that can't go to
something does have to be here but maybe
it's just this
does that make that whole it does make
that hold okay
but now you want hold unless that helps
Maybe
I still don't think there's gonna be
enough
every time it gets further I'm like
okay
can these make little steps
that I can use to like connect
so things are a little bit more together
I'm not sure how the round pieces work
bigger cue
Maybe
I feel like I'm just adding weight but I
don't really feel like you think that
way when you build in Lego
[Music]
I don't know 30.
that piece is doing nothing
[Music]
hmm
no
which I need to worry about it making
lighter maybe support those two with the
six by one underneath the middle yeah
oh it what
Q
just kind of holding onto itself though
if I do that right what is it even
connecting
nothing
what if I spin that that way does that
help
is that a useful thing to do I don't
think so I don't think so
top side of the bridge be looking flush
though
very flush
uh
um turn them
perpendicularly try rotating them
I don't know where I put them though do
you know what I mean
maybe maybe just on the outside
with the middle
Maybe
like here
it's not nothing it's not nothing
it's not enough I feel like I do need to
use every piece
where are you weak
still right there
it's just not enough that's barely doing
anything there's no way that I can hold
it together
there's no way there's no way that could
hold it together oh my God it is just
that on the other side as well
but
there's no way
it's too simple there's no way
no no
I was like but how but how could it have
support from underneath that it's just
heavier
what am I focused too much on adding
weight
yeah I am I really am I'm focused way
too much on worrying that a bottom heavy
bridge is not going to be able to
support itself
but a bottom heavy Lego can support
itself you know what they say about
bottom heavy you could still support
yourself you you don't need no man
uh
here
I almost don't want to do it
what should I do with the rest of the
pieces
surely we're not done here
it's I don't want to let it go
you know
I don't want to be I don't uh I'm not
done yet
I mean
what do you think happens if I take
these off
is this too chaotic
this is a bad idea
I don't wanna I just don't want to
finish it
I was like What if I take them off and I
add more of these pieces to make it look
nicer
no it's fine I think the robot can do it
now
buddy
look at you go my guy
it's right here should I hit the back
button
it's very tempting
I'm very proud thank you for helping me
on this journey everybody
definitely not something I'm talented at
um I want to thank my mom
first and foremost she's actually an
accountant very good at math my dad is
well he does accounting stuff too I
don't know how I ended up like this
[Music]
um it's a real struggle for me and I got
through this today
and I'm angry that actually all it
required was a couple extra supports on
the side because I was convinced that
that would weigh it down and so then
when the robot came over it it would
Buckle under the weight of the robot I
was I was just so sure that that would
be a problem
if I made the bridge bottom heavy
it would buckle and um
I'd like to thank everybody else here
today
and this skinny ass robot for his
assistance it really means a lot
um
and I really want to thank Lego
bricktails uh for sponsoring the stream
slash video
um
Games available now on PC steam epic
games.gov PS5 Xbox series X Nintendo
switch PS4 and Xbox One
and um
now I know how to build a bridge so
we all built the bridge together really
thank you
get the game right now and you could as
you see you could build this bridge in
less than I don't know 20 minutes how
long did it take you to build the bridge